[Music]
and about seven minutes in i said
this is gonna change my life straight up
you got your perspective
[Applause]
i just wanna be happy don't you wanna be
happy
gary vaynerchuk yeah did i pronounce
that correctly
i think he did a good job gary thank you
for joining us appreciate it matt i
really appreciate your time
and uh i'm excited to be here yeah yeah
for sure so let's jump right into it
uh our show is a little different
because you know we break down the
business models we break down
entrepreneur's success so like when we
had mark cuban on shout out to marketing
we asked him about his deal that he did
when he sold it and then he you know
hedged the stock and he gave a great
explanation so a lot of people might or
they may or they may not
know your story they heard the story
about you started in the wine business
your family's wine business right in in
the late 90s
and turned it from 3 million operation
to i believe a 60 million
operation and you did it it was early in
it called digital real estate
um and uh first wine e-commerce platform
so can you talk about that how you
had the foresight and how you actually
transitioned that and how you was early
on to the e-commerce phase timing's
incredible
about this i just literally literally
got off the phone
with my six best buds from college
shout out to 301 to spot ms iraq
dustin tokyo joe and glenn
um it was there in mount ida college
in newton mass in 1995
when keep from maine
and we had nicknames for everybody pete
from maine
said come and check this out and i heard
koo kooch
for the first time and i said
the [ __ ] is this and he's like this is
the world wide web and i was like i
heard about that [ __ ]
and i i what this is how cr for the kids
that are listening this is how crazy
internet was in 94.95
i waited my turn to get on the computer
to go on aol
it was so crazy this thing like being on
the internet and seeing people in chat
rooms
that i watched it as a spectator while
my man was on
the keyboard and i finally like an hour
later
sat down and clicked a couple buttons
and found myself
on a baseball card bulletin board in aol
and about seven minutes into my internet
life which was this
i said this is gonna change my life
straight up
just like that like straight out of
[ __ ] movie and and
that started the conversation in my head
which late
to six months later saying to my dad dad
we need a website for the liquor store
we didn't have a computer my dad didn't
take credit cards
like he was old school yeah i was born
in the soviet union
he's like cash only doesn't trust people
like wouldn't take checks
doesn't believe in anybody like you know
like all that stuff like
and and i got him there i just
completely knew
the same you know it's funny the one
skill i really have
is my intuition about things and people
is
heavy like it's just really my biggest
thing
so like literally looking at the
internet or looking at the investments i
made facebook twitter
coinbase or the fact that i bought
bitcoin in 2014
is no different than me thinking that
gunna
or the baby we're going to be good or
that
that that i thought alvin kamara was
going to be a good player when we
started vayner sports
even though he was the backup running
back at tennessee there's something in
me
that understands people and understands
what people are gonna do
and that's been my whole life like if i
was an a
r guy i would dominate if i was a
scientist like
looking at spiders for 20 years in the
woods i would figure it out like
that's my thing and so
that's what happened with the internet
that's how it started and i you know my
mission
in my 20s you know i was came to this
country with nothing i was born in
russia
lived in a studio in queens with like
eight family members like i grew up
rugged like my mom was
frugal and wasn't about didn't have
money so i was like
if i wanted nintendo if i wanted stuff i
had to buy it as a kid
so i'd always fight for money and
business
and my number one goal was to help my
parents
liquor store business like i gave up my
20s all of my 20s men
when kids talk to me about like oh
i'm like i gave up all my 20s to build a
business for my parents i left with
zero ownership of that business and i
blew that business up from three to
sixty million
and you know sometimes people try to rag
on me like ah you got handed [ __ ] i'm
like you think that's what happened
let me tell you the truth i took a
business from three to sixty million
never got paid [ __ ] because in the
family business you put all back in the
business
so it's one thing if you make money for
somebody else in a corporation but at
least you get paid a million dollars a
year i was getting paid 50
60 70 000 a year building a big ass
business
and at 34 years old left and had to
start my company in somebody else's
conference room vaynermedia
in buddy media's conference room because
i don't have the money to
pay rent so this is this is pre-social
media so what
strategies are you using to build a
company from three to sixty
right because this i mean internet has
just been developing yep
back then it was email and google
adwords that really took me off
right and banner ads people used to
click banner ads kids
i would buy banner ad for five hundred
dollars a month on a website
like wine. like a winespectator.com and
people clicked that [ __ ]
you know back then everyone was curious
about everything like banners like oh
cool it was kind of like cool you're
like empty oh [ __ ] takes me somewhere
else like
you know you know again i'm talking like
it's a hundred years ago
it's only 25 years ago but it's like 10
it's like a
it's a lifetime ago it was crazy there
was no laptops like you had to sit on a
[ __ ] desk to be on the internet this
feels like a a
scene in the wreck-it ralph movie he's
just presented
but so banner ads being you know
a little early social called forums
remember bulletin boards
i was part i was part of those all the
wine boards they're like
why do you know so much i i i own or my
family owns or
my dad and i run this place called wine
library check it out winelibrary.com
two clicks five clicks like real like
bricklaying
you know and then and then i figured out
email in 97
i was like okay this is gonna be big and
so i just started asking every customer
that came into the liquor store you got
an email
and this again back to the old days 25
years ago
people like yeah i got an email it's aol
yahoo.com
you know like it was but it was crazy
luckily the store was in jersey
where a lot of people worked on wall
street and the wall street cats had
email pretty early
and so you know started getting that
wall street clientele
and that's you know i really started
changing our business but
catalogs are the catalogs direct mail
newspaper page ads in the new york times
and wall street journal and
star ledger and jersey big shout out
when i was you know when i made a couple
bucks and was able to put them on you
know it was all
family immigrant businesses are you
don't take money out to buy [ __ ] you put
it back in the business back in the
business back in the business
so one of the reasons i never really
amassed a lot of money
during that time was my dad wasn't
paying me or him
any real money every dollar was back
into advertising back into
more employees back back back and so we
were feeding
one of the reasons i tell a lot of
entrepreneurs now like feed your
business
you know everyone wants to be an
entrepreneur to take it out and buy a
[ __ ] rollie
and right and buy a bet and like and buy
like some
and i'm like no no no no don't flex yet
you just started
put it back in back in your watch will
be more expensive
your trip will be nicer your flying
accommodations will be better
but you got to feed your business for a
minute
yeah stay down till you come up so you
you talked about
um how you left the company and left
with zero
so you left with what hey why did you
leave so it's a family business you grew
it it's 60 million dollars
is you know going nicely 10x the whole
situation or 20x whole situation
so why why did you leave and on some
real [ __ ]
three three main reasons resentment
my brother's 11 years younger than me
and i love my pops
let me break them down for you because
you guys go deep here i'm going to give
it to you
[ __ ] that i don't usually talk about
yeah
you work 15 hours a day including
saturdays because you're in the retail
business
from 22 to 32 years old no fun
no trips work 15 hours a day real [ __ ]
now not like [ __ ] like
propaganda or people acting like they're
working in the store
8 a.m leave the store 10 p.m in the
store
7 a.m leave the store 11 p.m for [ __ ]
10 years
and you take it from 3.8 million
to 60 and you have no real real real
money like that
and now you're married and you've got a
little bit of that right
you start being [ __ ] up a little
yeah yeah got it i'm just talking real
quick
i was like yo i was a kid i you know now
listen the reason i wasn't really [ __ ]
up and it was okay was
i wanted that i wanted to pay my parents
back i knew i was [ __ ]
great i knew it i knew what's going on
with me right now
and on some record on the record [ __ ] i
haven't even started
no i'm really i'm being really honest
with you guys like you're gonna look
you're gonna look at this video and in
13 years you'll be like damn he really
wasn't even like
in the same universe like i mean it i
really feel like i'm just starting i'm
patient
i know life is long i have wisdom i hung
out with old
old grandparents all the time as a kid
and i never understood why now i
understand i'm an old soul
i was patient i knew i could give up my
20s for my parents
feel good about that feel like i really
put them on because they put me on
be like you know settle that settle that
bread you know what i mean now
now we're good now we really i was a
little bit like that i needed it for me
but i really love my parents on some
real [ __ ] they're the best i was like
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna get mine regardless let me
really do something here
but now after a decade i started getting
into that little place of like
number two my brother's 11 years younger
than me my parents were 20
when they had me like that old russia
[ __ ] you know like
so so my brother was coming up and he
didn't want to work with my dad my dad's
a tough like
my dad's a different kind of personality
old school he didn't want to be about
that
and so i wanted to jam with him i mean
you know i've been teaching him
entrepreneurship since he was a kid ebay
garage sales all that [ __ ] that people
know about me so
i really wanted to jam with him so we
kind of decided somewhere around his
senior high school freshman year college
like we're going to do this so that was
in the back of my mind and
you know i left when he graduated he
graduated in may
of 2009 and i left started vaynermedia
but i was doing both i was doing wine
library
vaynermedia from 2009 to 2011.
and then number three i love my dad let
me explain
my dad was one of the guys he was one of
the 10 15 guys in the liquor business in
jersey he had one of the good stores
doing 4 million in a liquor store in the
80s that's real money
you know it's different day different
age there was no major players liquor
is fragmented you don't have walmarts
and [ __ ] like that so
he was a guy he was one of the guys he
was one of the people that could throw
around some clout
he was one of the bigger buyers and he
loved it he loved it
i came along and took that [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] moon
so i became the guy
and so now all of a sudden the you see
where i'm going right now
yeah all of a sudden my dad lost his
clout yeah and my dad
and i wasn't about sharing it either
because i took the wheel and was like
nah one person can drive so like go in
the passenger seat i love you dad
you're still my dad and you can always
call that once in a blue moon dad card
and make me do something i don't want to
do but 98 of time i'm driving
and the first year that i did the
business
he was renovating and decided to build a
new house for him and my mom
he loves construction so they built a
new house and that first year we went
from 4 to 10 million
and he kind of looked he's like [ __ ] 23
right i love you guys so he was like
i love you but [ __ ] i'm not going to
mess with this
next year 17 and he's like okay i got
something and so but what that did was
i was willing to do it for him but i was
going to take the shine i was gonna have
the leverage i was gonna be the guy
and and i loved my dad and we were
starting to have
conflict it was pretty cool for the
first eight or nine years little things
but now we were starting to have
consistent conflict i had my resentment
up
i become real famous in the liquor
business the guy guy
and nobody gave a [ __ ] about my dad and
i saw the pain in his eyes and it hurt
me because i love my dad
and people forgot about his part he came
to america with no language
he came to america with no money he came
to america and took all the risk
and went from and what he did from zero
to what he did
i know i'm going to the tippy top of all
time and i'm still going to always
admire what he did from zero to that
spot
right and i have my own zero story but
it's different
and he's my dad and so it just felt like
the right time if that makes sense
yeah that's that trust me that's that's
an honest answer so when you start the
media company
i'm assuming yeah so you learn early as
far as
emails and internet marketing and all of
that so
you just transitioned that into
the yes i'll give it to you yeah yeah
2006 youtube comes out i'm like this is
gonna be big
i hate it again why did you why did you
think youtube was gonna be big
because i thought the internet was gonna
take over the world and here was the
first thing i ever saw that did videos
proper
you know and i was like this is it and
and you know what's beautiful about
being old
is you got the receipts go to youtube
type in wine library episode one
february 21st 2006 when it was still
independent google hadn't even bought it
i saw it the video starts with me saying
i think this is the first wine show on
the internet like you know what i mean
like
yeah i watched it i watched it i
appreciate it
so i saw it i did it and
i was right and then youtube sells for
one seven 1.7 billion into
in 2007 and to help everybody here
that be like tick tock selling for a
trillion
to facebook right now the number was
crazy back then one
seven was like
like you didn't even think about [ __ ]
like that right and so
that happened and that's when my career
really took off i said wait a minute
i was right about dot com i was right
about email i was right about google
adwords
i was right about you know blogging even
though i didn't do it
i was right about this youtube thing
maybe i'm not just a good businessman or
liquor store runner or
seller i might be good at like just
knowing [ __ ]
that's literally the combo i had with
myself and i read an
article that youtube had angel investors
and i was like what's an angel investor
and i googled it
and i was like i'm gonna be an angel
investor and then next year
i went to south by southwest because i
got to put you got to put yourself in it
if you're going to be in it i went to
silicon valley a bunch and within the
year of me deciding
that chew up that 150 i don't remember
80 to 150k i saved
because i was living in a [ __ ]
apartment never going out
so even though i was making 50 i was
saving four thousand a year
making 67 8 000 a year you see what i'm
saying
so when i tell kids with my content like
be humble
i lived i don't give advice that i
[ __ ] read in a book
i don't get advice that i didn't live
so because i was living humble and not
buying dumb [ __ ]
even though i wasn't making much i had a
little something
and now i saw this opportunity and the
first three companies i invested in
were facebook twitter and tumblr
and it changed my life so the angel
conversation is extremely interesting
because a lot of people might not know
your angel investors so that's a that's
a perfect three companies to invest in
so
angel invest in vc world is like you
know people have been around for
decades that do that with billions of
dollars so you come even with a couple
of hundred thousand that's not really
real money interviews
different than though like i invested in
tumblr's b round at 14 million
evaluation a b round now is like 400
million
it was a different world when i did it
nobody there was nobody coming at these
kids like that back then nobody believed
in the internet like this
like i was able to talk to mark
zuckerberg to ed williams to david carr
like i was talking to the person it just
wasn't that shine like it was it was
like hip hop 85 versus hip hop today so
that's
it basketball so so for the what round
did you get in facebook
so facebook i bought from mark's parents
two years before the ipo because i
became friendly with the facebook crew
and randy
and mark because randy and her sister
worked at the company i'd flown out to
speak to the company
i would hang with them at conferences so
one day i just got a call from randy
saying you know my parents want to sell
some of the
facebook stock before the ipo because
they want to move to california and
build a house
and be near us would you like something
she didn't
start she didn't finish saying my
parents
and i rewired the money cause i knew
facebook was gonna win
and then tumblr was one of the big
companies out of new york
because [ __ ] wasn't happening in new
york so tumblr was out of new york and i
noticed
junior high kids were on tumblr
in 2008 2007 and i was like wait that
might be next because all the youngsters
are on it
and so i got on there and then yahoo
bought tumblr for a billion
[Music]
follow the youth so so as far as like
the angel investing you know about the
rounds can you explain that a little bit
because people hear about rounds seed
round fun round a round b round c round
but they might not actually know what
that actually means
team you know a lot of people use
different terminology for the same ship
but like
you know the angel round is the initial
money in
then usually the the first time a
company takes money the angel the seed
investment or the angel
right high risk like most of my angel
investments went to zero but high reward
you come in early on something it can
get real crazy
you know i angel the company called
barkbox that's about to go public
that's gonna get interesting for me you
know angel
you can get crazy um so
then there's the a then it just goes and
then it goes in very simple order for
everybody the a route
it's kind of the first real money you
know five million bucks three million
bucks
then the b round 10 20 million bucks
then the c round
that's you know when i said 10 20 that's
how much they took in so they got a 100
million dollar valuation
and they took a 20 million dollars and
now that person invested
is in only 15 percent of the company
that gives that nature because it's 120
close trade for 20.
so that's how it goes angel abcd
and usually by after d you're looking at
going public or selling
so like a couple questions in regards to
that for entrepreneurs
how should they prepare themselves to
approach an angel investor like what
should they already have in place
because from my understanding
a company has to have a certain amount
of revenue like already in place before
they can actually get venture capital or
angel money
is that true or no angel money you can
get when you have nothing
an idea now that comes with privilege
right let's be very honest here and i'm
not even talking white
privilege i'm talking rich privilege i
know unlimited black asian
trans you know if you're running in
money circles you got a shot
to get money on an idea
you know one of the reasons i stopped
investing and i don't invest that much
most of my money right now is going to
sports cards we can get into that before
we get out of here
yeah yeah um is it's crazy now
like you can get you can basically say
i'm going to build this
make a deck go to people and they give
you money
based on a four million dollar five
million dollar six million dollar seven
million dollar valuation
but but it's a very small group of
people that have access to that capital
right
and they usually run from high
university stanford harvard right
or they run in very rich circles your
mom and dad
have wealth and you know their friends
happy to write you a 250
000 check at that valuation then you use
that to get another person so
you know you don't need to be making
money
and ironically in technology it's almost
better that you're not
people like to invest more in the idea
once you start making money they have
something to
judge you on it's a crazy system and i'm
not a
i that that concerns me and which is why
i've been hesitant
to go hard in an early stage i like
it a little bit later where people prove
it a little now no reason to take that
risk
so i'm aware of an a and b guy if i
really get excited
so when you when you actually are going
to go after a company or decide to
invest it
is is that why you created vayner x or
is that something different right
because that became a holding company at
a certain point right
vaynerx is different i did have a so i
did angel investing and real well then i
got hooked up with steve ross the owner
miami dolphins and he
bought a piece of vaynermedia which was
the first company vaynermedia
which later became vaynerx when i
started adding companies so i needed a
holding company
for the companies okay i'll get to that
in a minute
when when steve ross invested in vayner
bought a piece excuse me at vaynermedia
he also put up the money for a fund and
i deployed 25 million dollars
out of a fund as a like a fund right so
for everyone listening because we're
doing some real good educating here that
means
that i got i normally get paid two
percent
of the number to manage it but because i
didn't take that from him because he
already bought a piece of my company and
we're kind of being homies
but i got 20 of the back end right so 20
of all the earnings so the 25 goes and i
get
20 of anything that happens right
you know so i don't put up the money i
make the decisions but that gives me 20
cents on a dollar he gets 80 cents
and with that company i made a lot of
smart investments i
started a company with that money called
resi resy
anybody who's into restaurants the resi
app that was me we sold that company
for nine figures to amx 18 months ago
i invested in snapchat pinterest
coinbase so we did real well
so you talk about the holding the
holding companies why is that
why is that important that's important
because i had vaynermedia one company
and then i wanted to buy a new company
called purewow there
is a women's lifestyle brand uh com
publisher
similar to refinery219 or bustle
you know i just stood up a men's brand
called 137 pm that everybody should
check out that's more like complex
advice
so when i bought that company i didn't
want to put it into vaynermedia because
it was a different kind of company
different taxes different all that
so i created a holding company called
vaynerx one side of it was vaynermedia
another side was what we call the
gallery media group which held
purewow in it then we started 1 37 p.m
and then i started going ham i started a
new company called sasha group
after my dad sasha to be vaynermedia for
small businesses
then i started the speaking bureau
vayner speakers then i started
a company for e-commerce vayner commerce
you know i just started going now and so
i've got a series of businesses now
we just set up a new company called
vaynertalent where we help people build
their personal brand and we represent
and manage some people so now i got my
holding code and the way you do
the reason i sit at the top of the
holding code i'm the active ceo of
vaynermedia but i got people running the
other companies
and you create incentive plans for them
at their level it all ladders up to the
big level
and that's where i'm at there you have
it um so as far as
one last question about the angel what
do you look for because you
obviously had a bunch of success
facebook twitter tumblr uh
uber snap venmo to name a few so it's
not luck
so you obviously have an eye for talent
more so than i mean a gut feeling yeah
but
do you have anything that you like a
checklist where you look for
100 two things my conviction of what's
going on in life
and then the person so i called the
jockey and the horse
i gotta pick the horse let me give you
one right now for everybody i'm gonna
make some people some money today
nft nft is
stands for non-fungible tokens crypto
art
right so on top of it we've got a
conversation about this
so this is coming i believe in it
there's gonna be a lot of money lost
so don't go crazy everyone who's
listening yeah yeah spend 100 hours let
me say it slowly so it sinks in
everyone's head
100 hours 100 hours
of education then maybe you go buy a
piece of crypto art
but i now believe in nft i really
believe in it
now i got to go find people that i
believe in that can ride that horse so i
make a decision on the horse
but then i got to believe in the jockey
i lost a lot of money my first round
2007 8 9 10 11 12. because i was right
about the
concept but i was wrong about the
person's stomach who was running it
she or he couldn't take a punch you
understand
yeah that's what i'm looking for now who
can take a punch
that's what entrepreneurship is
entrepreneurship is ufc
entrepreneurship is boxing who can take
a punch
so i'm right about a lot of stuff to
your point i've got a great career on
that
but i've now what i'm spending more time
on is can she do it
is he about that life and and and i'm
trying to spend more time on that and i
think i've done better lately
yeah so so i mean i've watched the
videos man and like you said there are
receipts so creating
and finding global trends is your thing
i watched it when you said that facebook
is going to be sold to ig in 2011.
i saw when you used it facebook sold
yeah and then and then the joe rogan to
spotify and so
is nft the next thing or is this there's
something yo that was crazy
is there is there something else nft is
going to happen
uh something else i'm about audio i've
talked about that a lot now you see club
i'm getting a lot of love again because
of clubhouse
i was about audio i was kept yelling
audio audio audio
um
[Music]
premium sports cars lebron kobe jordan
you know um nft nft i feel
is really solidified on that's great we
just who
who had that conversation we had we had
the the so somebody text us one of our
patreon members texted us about text me
about the digital art
in that that space and then we had it
with 19 keys oh yeah she said the same
thing
yeah he was explaining he was in miami
we sat down with a good friend of ours
and he he was explaining us to us about
crypto and digital art
and i didn't really understand it and he
took like a half an hour and he was like
if you have like a art showing and it's
like that the
the artist like leases out the image for
just that in the virtual world yeah
it was a whole thing and that's the
first time and it's crazy that you
mentioned that because that's the first
time i ever heard of it last week and
now you're bringing it up again
let me bring up something else that's
going to make it work
the other thing i was going to answer
you on in combination with crypto are
like call it nft non-functional tokens
like digital r crypto art
is vr so
look we're basically in vr now
think about what everybody take a step
back i'm going to make it real common
sense
how much time are you in your phone
think about how many minutes a day
you're looking at your phone
there could be a rhinoceros behind you
you have no idea
so the the jump step
to oculus right
aka i'm predicting in 10 15 years you're
not going to need some big ass
thing on your eyes you're going to be
contact lensed and then
if we live in a virtual world six hours
a day which i predict will happen to
everybody who's listening here
now i think that's 10 15 20. but i'm
patient
if if we live virtually you have to
understand why blockchain
crypto nfts matter because you can prove
that you own it
it's on the blockchain it's on the left
so you're the only one with it
now imagine if you're the only one in it
if you imagine blockchain integration of
vr
when somebody's coming to your pad and
you're like living it
like it's gonna feel like we're living
and the same reason people flex art
you see where this is going yeah yeah
yeah okay can we can we go back to the
the collectible cards
because i know that i mean that's your
origin so this must feel like surreal
like yo this is coming back
the biggest reason the biggest reason so
many of my friends my brother my best
friends didn't believe me three years
ago is i think they thought i was
thinking with my heart got it
because yeah because i mean that was
that was the beginning when i was like
when i was like why is nobody believing
me three years ago and i was like yo i
got receipts now listen to me
and i was like oh [ __ ] the people that
believe in me the most that love me the
most that know me the most
they think i'm in love
right because you're right it is my
first love that's like cards
in 1987 to 1993 that's when i became
garyvee
like what i am built on today is those
six years of doing sports card shows
being with grown ass men and winning
so as a child yeah i i remember that i'm
gonna let you go but i remember being
that kid from like 91 i was collecting
baseball cards and basketball cards and
marvel cards and i was like i gotta save
these i think the most valuable one i
could think we had was a
ken griffey jr rookie card and i'm like
i'm holding this forever
i still have it it's like worth like i
think it's mint nine or something like
that it might be worth like six seven
hundred dollars but i'm like i'm keeping
this forever
so what's the deal with this new virtual
wave that you're speaking of with
i'm not familiar with this whole
situation so what's what is this
virtual cards no like the trading cards
like baseball cards i know but like it
is like a new age of that
well there is something there is two
things brewing there's nba topshop
i don't know if you've seen that but
that's oh i think i did yeah yeah
they like the holograms that's well
they're like highlights
highlights on the blockchain so that's
we're talking a little bit now
of nft the [ __ ] we were talking about
earlier nba top shops huge
and there's a soccer one proper football
coach so rare
built on top of ethereum okay and that's
a word people
starting to hear now right because
that's different than bitcoin but the
other thing that has heat because it's a
platform that people build on top of
like so rare
so um
yeah there's a little bit of that bruin
but yeah the sports card thing three
years ago i saw it i'm like this is next
this is next and
you know again like i said earlier
charlie demilio
sports cards uber gunna
little keyed you know snapchat
like it's all the same game for me what
do i see that nobody else sees
as easily as i see it am i tricking my i
always ask myself am i tricking myself
so i double check a triple check a
quadruple check
and the receipts are there the youtube
videos of me and charlie demillo before
she went
there the videos of me and keith and
gunna they're they're there
so you your social media acumen is
highly respected one of the best ever
during social media so talking about the
next phase
where we at next obviously clubhouse
tick tock
how do you feel like do you feel because
i think facebook just announced
something that they're gonna do
something similar to what
um clubhouse has gone to is it is it
here to stay or is it
the next vine it's snapchat let me
explain clubhouse is snapchat
snapchat's still here remember when it's
like i remember i was like it's dead i'm
like it's not dead it got dented
instagram gave it a punch you know it
took an hell it
it might have lost it it definitely fell
down
but it's come back to you know the
rematch always matters right
and snap is doing quite well they're
building a really nice company
but instagram took off even more because
of it so
stories became a format not just an app
got it so now you have snap doing well
but every platform
twitter linkedin youtube facebook
instagram
has stories i think the same thing is
going to happen with clubhouse
clubhouse is going to continue to
innovate and do its thing
but i believe that every single platform
facebook
instagram linkedin twitter are all going
to have
clubhouse-like dynamics in it and it's
going to be a feature
in the biggest platforms in the world so
so can a clubhouse survive because we
saw this with vine when they had the
eight second clip and then instagram
they took it no that's just you know
that's where people get their history
wrong
vine won let me explain mine sold their
company to twitter
vine died because the guys left vine
didn't have to die
vine took the bag
let's win no snap of course it can look
at snap
snaps just fine at all-time highs on its
stock yeah they start
i was about to say the starting stock
come on stock is going well yeah
so yes man of course clubhouse can now
snap
was probably further along when that
feature happened on instagram
so what clubhouse has to worry about is
if all these companies come at them from
all different directions
can they continue to grow or will people
do what happened
you know i'm sure you remember this when
instagram did that
thing everyone's like oh good i don't
have to be on snapchat because they're
insecure because they only had a
thousand dollars there and they had a
million over here
like everyone's on their insecure [ __ ]
but i was staying on both because the
tension is attention
so what you know right now people are
insecure they're not even in clubhouse
they don't have an
invite so when twitter pops it up or
instagram pops it up they're like yeah
you know what i mean
i don't have to go there i'm not behind
um
so that's what that's what clubhouse has
to worry about what about tick tock
you know tick tock is a beast tick tock
has it's just on fire i think people are
completely confused what's going on if
you're under 25 it's tick tock
comma instagram and it's not even close
tik tok will be interesting they're so
about their world their algorithm
finding creativity
if you ask me which platform's most
likely not to do
audio like that i would say it's tick
tock and snap
i don't see a shot that linkedin youtube
and facebook and instagram don't do it
twitter's already done it
yeah it's interesting because it's like
for entrepreneurs you get
comfortable with one platform and then
another platform comes out and it's like
you're spinning in all different
directions so what's your advice for
people that may not have a budget to
hire you know a whole staff and it's
like
they just focus on one thing they got
instagram figured out and now they kind
of like you said
they built a nice following on instagram
and they feel like they got to start at
zero
on tick tock or zero on clubhouse
multiple things one
crying about it and could do [ __ ] that's
the game
sorry like you know like you know like
people had
people had mtv and bt figured out and
napster came along
and [ __ ] up their game right [ __ ]
happens sorry
if you're an entrepreneur you're in the
business of getting punched in the face
nobody owes you anything so that's
number one that's what i tell them
number two you don't start at zero if
you've got a million followers on
instagram
you post a little photo i'm gonna be on
clubhouse at 8pm
you know what i mean so you're not
starting at zero your audience is moving
with you
i got half a million followers already
on clubhouse i've barely been on it
because i've been busy
you know what i mean you don't start at
zero your equity travels
yeah can we can i talk about one of my
favorite quotes as you said it was it's
uh the empty the bucket
and it's true in relationships and it
was like i was living that i was like
it's tough to be in a marriage where you
you have something on your mind that you
you you fester because after a while the
bucket overflows but
can you talk about the importance of
that in business of emptying the bucket
it's life resentment's a problem and for
me
i can deal with i can eat [ __ ] i can
fill that bucket
because i'm a big picture i'm empathetic
but even for me it
tips over and for my dad he was the
reverse i always said to my dad dad
your buckets the size of this cup my
bucket's the size of the ocean
that's where you and i are different he
would get triggered quick
you know and for me i would just eat
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] it was even my leverage
you know i would like but like the
reality is candor matters
now i like kind candor if you're gonna
tell somebody the truth deliver it with
some compassion
not like yo you stink you know what i
mean like you know like you gotta think
that through
but yeah you have to be careful of
resentment you have to be careful
of holding [ __ ] in because it's not
sustainable that shit's gonna
come out either in you doing bad
behavior
right alcohol like people humans need
escape from unhappiness
you know and so you gotta get [ __ ] off
your chest and so i think a lot about
that
and i've historically not been great at
it i've been lucky because my bucket's
an ocean
but even the ocean overflows at times
and those have not been good events in
my life and i'm trying to stay away from
that
and so i'm trying to empty it more often
and emptying it emptying the bucket
means
go and have kind candor and talk [ __ ]
out communication
heals everything even the hard talks and
and and when you're most upset you have
to be most compassionate to the other
side
not the other way around because if you
come in hot they're going to react hot
and the next thing you know you come to
blows whether physically or verbally and
that's never a good thing
the ocean becomes a tsunami yeah exactly
one last before we wrap um underpriced
attention i know you're big on
obviously social media but for
entrepreneur is that is that
the only way to get underpriced
attention these days or are there other
hacks that you know business owners
entrepreneurs creatives can go about to
get their brand out there and the name
out there internet the internet is
underpriced attention
or doing like a stunt right like if you
like
paint a street or something or like you
know like you got to do something like
shocks the world in real life go viral
go viral but that's hard
it's hard hard whereas on the internet
linkedin's organic reaches through the
roof tick tocks organic you could be
nobody
quote unquote no audience make one tick
tock the first one and go off
how do you not take advantage of that
right clubhouse right now how do you not
go on
if you're trying to build an audience
you should be living on clubhouse
people just looking for rooms and new
people to follow so
yeah the internet and social networks
especially are the spot
but it's the content you put into it
that's contextual
yeah it's all about content content
content is king
and it's cash content is cash and king
gary it's been a pleasure brother this
is you know what this is this has been
long overdue
um two years ago we ran into you at the
k-swiss booth
yeah and we said look remember that i
remember are you kidding me you know
much pressure i've been feeling about
this interview
it was it was documented your fan base
is harassing me i feel
guilty and [ __ ] cause i [ __ ] with you
guys and i'm just trying to balance my
life out here i'm busy as [ __ ] and like
and then you know like the way life
actually works you end up doing somebody
else's thing before like that i just met
last week
and i still know in the back of my head
i got these two good looking dudes that
i got to do with this with
and so like i'm [ __ ] happy as [ __ ] we
finally
yeah did put it on instagram it was like
ten thousand of his words i'm like tag
them
yeah we did this man i'm cheering for
you guys heavy it's been fun to watch
from afar
you continue to build bricks over these
last two years i cheer for you heavy if
i can ever get you somebody you can't
get to
i'm a i'm a dm away and uh and i hope
you have a great great great 20 21.
appreciate that brother shout out to
charlemagne for uh connecting the dots
on yeah
yeah shot the god put the final piece in
there
yeah man but yeah just you you were a
man of your word then um and i'm so
happy that we got it done and
we're neighbors on the charts too so it
makes it makes perfect sense listen
you guys are doing real work i'm really
proud of that that that little
that little humble brag you just put out
it's real i'm proud of you guys you're
doing real work it's brick by brick
listen
i did wine library tv for 18 months
nobody knew who the [ __ ] i was
i told you guys earlier in 13 years 50
000 times more people are gonna know who
i am i'm just starting to we're all on
our journey
and it's the journey it's the bricks you
know what i mean
yeah like like i swear to god you might
not believe this
i don't know my numbers i don't know
where i'm in the charts it just
you know like i'm just so tunneled back
to the horse and the jock you know those
horses they put the
liners on the sides like i don't know
where i rank
i don't know where it is i don't you
know people trying to goad me into [ __ ]
all the time
i'm just focused i'm in my cocoon i'm in
my silence i'm in my
zone i'm just putting in work in the
dirty i'm not at the equinox i'm at a
dirty gym
that smells like [ __ ] getting in my reps
you know what i mean yeah that's it
that's like that rocky vibe
yeah down trees we begin coating that
like people like oh you guys are doing
so great and we're just like
so like looking ahead to what's coming
like yeah we got to stay focused
i tell my friends all the time don't get
fancy until it's time to get fancy
whoever holds their breath the longest
wins
bar's out here baby gary appreciate you
brother
you do botcha what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon